[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we're asking the question
how did we survive before cellphones or
mobile phones or smartphones mobile
phones that's all I can think of I think
that's what we call phones yeah this is
a little something that we're that we're
gonna try today a little something
different where we're actually going to
we're calling this a nostalgia nostalgia
tour how do you say how do you say that
word nostalgia
you don't say nostalgia nostalgia no
yeah cuz it's like when you get nauseous
thinking about things from the past you
get nostalgia I felt that sometimes but
I did I mean we may feel that over the
course of reminiscing over our
relationships with phones before
cellphones this interesting term
relationships because I might
I just might feel sick to my stomach
that this is how we used to live or that
I wish I still lived that way I haven't
quite figured that out but what I do
know is I mean frequently on your
biscuits will will reminisce about
things so I just thought less reminisce
within this category of what phones used
to be like right and so we've just we
thought of some things like remember
when well don't say I mean I'm sorry I'm
gonna make blanks I'm making blanks cuz
I have my list you have your list
remember when blankety blank blank blank
blank blank phones so that's how it's
gonna be and they'll be like remember
when blankety blank blank blank phones
right but before we reminisce let's talk
about the present day I mean let's talk
about the reality of being tethered yeah
I mean ironically you're tethered
wirelessly wirelessly tethered think
about that put that on a t-shirt I'm
tethered to a wireless phone that's not
really a sellable t-shirt I think yeah
last night Christi and I went out on a
date and were like we're we're driving
to the to the
restaurant I mean one word when we're at
the table having a date like we're not
we're not that couple who's just on our
phones and not talking to each other but
there are some times when something will
come up in conversation and the phone
will become a third party to our date
like a third wheel or it's like oh
there's unlimited information on this
thing but all the challenges the
challenges is went if you have to go to
the phone in the midst of a conversation
which happens often and there are
legitimate reasons to defer to the
Internet in the midst of a conversation
often during an argument go to effect
argue with my wife all the time about
facts
you know just anytime you need to
reference something temptation once you
have access to all the information in
the world you get your information you
know well what's on well yeah we buddy
luck Movado who you were driving can't
do that we were driving and like we're
we were are we already having us like a
serious not it we weren't having an
argument we were just curious we were
having like a discussion let's share
things that are in our hearts and minds
with each other let's get into that mode
even before we're at the restaurant it
happened naturally or did you prompt it
like a youth pastor I'd like to share
something for my heart in mind or was it
just natural was just natural like you
know our relationship is this vibrant as
ever and it's not facetious even though
it sounded that way yeah we were yeah we
were just talking you were just talking
like to normal people on a date and I
look over and she's on her phone now
unlike me she can do more than one thing
at once
so I do respect that she's also in the
she's not driving so and she's not
driving I was driving and talking that's
two things yeah well you but I wasn't
you don't do that well but Ike I was
kind of making an introspective point
and I thought it was I thought it was a
very great opportunity for connection
and she was listening but when I looked
over there and she was on her phone I
was like do you have to be on your phone
right now I'm kind of trying to make a
I'm trying to make a point about
something this feels important to me and
she's like well look at this dog hug
this cat no she was actually talking to
the babysitter who whoever coordinating
the time that we would come back home so
it was a legitimate exercise but I was
like because she was like I have to he
she has to leave and now I know when
we're getting back and I have to tell
her and she needs to know right now but
so I was barking up the wrong tree but I
did feel like you know before the
cellphone if you what you would
coordinate all that you know you'd have
to go through all these great links to
do it but you didn't you weren't
constantly in conversation and once you
were gone you were gone you were gone
yeah I mean the emergency well even if
it what you do tell people what
restaurant you're going to I guess some
parents did
we were never parents without cell
phones so we don't know what it was like
to be a parent like that if my parents
first of all I don't remember my parents
having a date night that's like a modern
invention but would they have told the
babysitter we're going to be they
probably said this is what we're going
to do and this is when we're gonna be
back but they didn't say I'm paying you
to be completely in charge Yeah right I
mean I handle everything I'm not paying
you didn't text me with every little
little thing sidebar did I mean your
daughter is 15 years old
yeah you just why don't you just due to
babysitting
she don't want to take care of the kids
um well that's a good question you know
it's it that just doesn't work a lot of
times I'll just I'll just put it that
way
cuz I'm thinking about instituting my
date night right and just not having any
child care Oh what we do that I mean the
kids are old enough to take care of
themselves or Lillian Lincoln to help
watch over Lando but neither one of none
of them can drive and there's like
logistics that are happening like they
had to go to different places and stuff
like that anyway so it's sometimes we
haven't got to cover it with an adult we
have an ongoing arrangement so then she
she helps out with things like date
night too
but it's it's a much larger scope than
that but I look over at Christina my
okay okay I'm not I'm not gonna jump
down your throat about this but then I
swear when I looked over there again she
was on Instagram I just I I just have to
I think so
oh my wife is constantly on it well
might well what my wife found this year
was Twitter and that is just I mean
she's she's a Twitter holic man but when
there's and and it's not like we when we
have a spare moment you
find yourself reaching for your phone
watch pulling that thing out I mean it's
it's a it's um almost a mindless reflex
to pull that thing out oh yeah I mean
factly on it I saw somebody tweet the
other day do you remember what it was
like to just poop yeah don't be on your
call you know what was it like to just
poop now I've made repeated pledges to
myself to not surf while pooping but I
just can't stick to it man have you
tried like putting a have you tried
pudding
have you tried pudding it goes right
through yeah putting a book on the back
of the toilet you know and then you're
you're tempted to read it mm-hmm have
you tried that I yeah why I used to read
books but I mean now that you can you
are used to reading books can you not
all the toilet let me let me clarify
you pull the have you tried pulling the
phone putting the phone away and pulling
out a book not since the phone was a
thing I got five taking a book to to the
crapper
yeah but then you're on it too long like
the phone is the perfect thing you just
get a little taste you shouldn't do any
of that though because sometimes you get
into you know so like an Instagram hole
and you're sitting the next thing you
know you got hemorrhoids yeah you can't
do that man you shouldn't even take it
in there it shouldn't work it should be
like those grocery stores that have like
some kind of scrambler on the on the
phones I'm convinced what's happening in
grocery stores well there's a scrambler
on the phones they put one in the DMV hi
compatible leave it I'm pulling out
recipes because I'm at the freaking
grocery store and I can I've got no
service I got like one X that I think I
was happening I don't think they have
any reason to block like cell signal in
there I think it's the exposed steel of
the thing is being blocked by just the
structure by this but well how come we
get you get cell phone signals while in
buildings and office all types is truck
like on the first floor
of a large office building your cell
phone works why doesn't it work in a
grocery store must be that's just the
groceries to think it's the food you
think food a food is absorbing the cell
signals yeah maybe maybe chips cuz
there's a lot of chips the chip tile is
gotten caught it correlated a signal to
different certain going away in certain
aisles definitely never gotten it in the
chips oil I don't know I could pull out
my phone right now and google it but I'm
not going I think we should just put our
phones in a bag of chips and see if it
works I mean this this podcast is an
exercise in you know I was gonna say
stamina but restraints is the word I'm
like sometimes is an exercise in stamina
and I think some listeners are like
nodding their head yeah I can barely get
through this but it's restraint because
we're not we're not going to our phones
we're just having a conversation for
like an hour
yeah with each other every week that's
boy that's healthy I put I put my phone
my phone on airplane mode when I do this
or airport motors you would say yeah I
did when I'm when I'm doing a podcast
that's what I do well let's let's
reminisce yeah cuz I've got a list of
things it's not it's not in direct
contrast to the mobile phones it's
things that are like I forget until I
started thinking about things I just
almost forgot existed like the way my
life in the world used to operate was so
different yes and you'll find out all
about that in a second but first we want
to let you know where you can get this
snazzy hoodie that link is wearing which
sometimes for some reason I call hoodies
beanies I think I got a weird weird
thing in my brain that wants me to call
it hoodie beanies never been a beanie
beanie so much nothing like just wearing
a shirt and then realizing I could I
could cover my hair with part of this
shirt and this hoodie has the latest in
hoodie technology it's called the
drawstring look at that it's a string
that goes through the hood can be tied
it can be left hanging
you can hang at different links at which
point it will
to stress some people depending on their
personality now my son my son told me
that if you tie your hoodie strings that
means you're in a relationship and if
you don't there's always stuff it means
that you're not well you're single
you're dangling but then you're or
you're tied up well okay
you know what it makes sense you know
what else they're doing Italy England
are tied up they're doing it in North
Carolina because I learned this from my
nephews if you're in a relationship you
wear the girls
scrunchie as a wristband is that right
you wear a wristband and apparently it's
color-coded like a certain color is I
don't I but definitely the scrunchie on
it she gives you the scrunchie it's is
like exclusive I've been scrunchie all
right go to mythical dot store and get
what crunchies what hey we need to start
selling scrunchies yeah okay that's what
the youth are into always looking for
something relationship scrunchies okay
no wait did you say the website mythical
ass to us in so we got our list here
let's see I mean I've got mine in in no
particular order that you want to go
first I don't know I don't know hit me
with one let's reminisce I'm gonna start
with payphones Oh
pay phone remember pay phone not even
phones at home the phones you had to pay
for
I keep imma grab my dog hold on yeah
well she's usually so docile and just
likes to sit in your lap but she seems
concerned about she's afraid to come up
here but she's intimidated by the new
innovation in hoodies let me let me just
give you a couple of facts well you know
what let's just see how bad you are with
numbers because that's always
entertaining how many I'm at a payphone
in 1999 even work in 1999 how many
payphones were there in the United
States of America well there's 50 states
I would say there's probably
the ten half in what year 1999 hold 99
20 years ago
yeah but cellphones existed then cell
phones were not in wide use at that
point no order of them half a million
payphones in operation or in existence
there's not a distinction just in
operation a lot I'm talking about like
apocalypse or ones in like next to the
Salton Sea or something I'm rounding up
a quarter of a million 252 million 2
million in 1999 and then how many in
March of 2018 well they're all still
there
when they're not working how many are in
service many of them are not in service
anymore but how many of them are in
service in 50,000 oh you're not hit bad
a hundred thousand so there's a hundred
thousand pay phones so this is super
interesting a fifth of them are in the
state of New York a fifth of all pay
phones that are active are in the state
of New York and one day you're there now
wouldn't it okay doesn't it seem like it
would be something logical if I told you
like there's a hundred thousand pay
phones left and I got this all from a
CNN money article by the way I just
didn't you know I'm not just making this
up if I told you there's only a hundred
thousand pay phones left in the United
States and they're all owned by one
billionaire or only all owned by one
company that would seems like yeah
there's one person who got into this old
technology yeah no those 100,000
payphones are controlled by 1100
independent providers that was
fascinating I mean when is the last time
you use the payphone and do you I don't
even remember really using payphones
much like back in the day well I'm about
to blow your mind because it's still a
business at least in 2015 it was I don't
know how many more operation not many
more than there are now in 2015 those
pay phones and operations generated 286
million dollars in revenue you talking
coinage going into the machines
well I guess possibly you'd maybe
collect calls we're also going to that
fit that number okay I guess I'm
assuming because it's the same person
provider now this is just fascinating me
so they're very useful still in certain
situations like when you're out of range
like apparently the payphones in
Yosemite Valley are very very like
there's a guy who owns those ah and he
makes a bunch of money off that oh so
it's because you don't work in these
national parks also disasters like when
when phones are the cell networks are
over overwhelmed or if there's like a
disaster and like there's completely
incapacitated like pay phones are very
useful so you would think that okay
we've kind of reached some sort of like
stasis a hundred thousand pay phones
probably what we need case of emergency
but there's a weird law that the FCC
passed that I didn't really read enough
about it to know exactly what was going
on but it essentially has to do with the
auditing that is required and apparently
the auditing that is required for these
payphones by the companies who are
servicing them costs more then they're
generating and so now it's becoming an
unsustainable business and payphones are
going out of business not the business
to get into unless they're able to talk
to FCC at least as of March of last year
out of this weird
regulation I don't know what they're
auditing it's a I think it's to make
sure that the right parties are paid for
the phone calls like the collect calls
it's the the calls that cost money
that's not coinage I don't know I did
again I didn't read that much I just
know that they're going away but like
having read about them I began to think
I should be using payphones more often
why what I mean do you have do you have
a strong memory of having a great
experience and a pay phone booth I've
never had a great experience in a pay
phone booth yeah but I mean it's you I
was always afraid to touch here like put
it up to my ear you don't have to touch
it you can just get it get a nice
distance I they were very weighty like I
remember a few tongues you pick up a
just next time you go buy a pay phone of
course they are just pick it up and like
pick up that receiver and that thing is
heavy
you know wise got to be so durable
think of all the beautiful people just
slamming it against slamming it down on
the thing after a bad phone call yeah
because a lot of the times you're in
like some sort of like frustrated
situation mmm on a payphone trying to
call home I'd like to have a phone that
durable at home well you could probably
buy a payphone and like hook it up at
your house I'm sure there's somebody now
you don't have a landline do you I do
you do I do and I had a lamb and I
talked about my landline in the context
of another
do you remember so-and-so well the one
on my list that you reminded me of is
beepers remember beeper sleepers man so
before a pers the new jeepers
aka pagers before before cell phones
came about and even as they were
starting to catch hold people are having
beepers in like the early 90s they're
like I mean I I think there was like a
drug cultural around brown beepers there
was also like that's a I mean I think
there might even a drug culture around
beepers meaning drug dealers all had
beepers yes that's what you meant but I
I mean it was also just something that I
learned about in hip-hop like there was
a tribe called quest song called the sky
pager sky pager
yeah and the low in theory and I was
like oh it's gonna be cool to have him
it'd be cool to have a beeper and then
fast-forward many years later I become
an engineer and I was issued a beeper
beeper I never had one
I had a beeper did you feel powerful and
you're like Batman I was released I had
I had a read about how it worked
because I even though I carried around
for a couple of years beeps man I
couldn't remember I would have to travel
between different facilities like I'd
get in my car and drive around and did
you have it on the outside of the Bell
different it would be on what we put it
in my underwear well it's some people
put it in a pocket I'm an engineer man
I'm walking around with my shirt tucked
in and I got a belt that's back when I
used to wear belts and I would hang it
on the belt with pride I and you should
have I'm just saying I didn't you don't
wear belts now and never see you know my
beat
so the beeper is like you know if I was
talking about kids about this or if
you've never heard of it it's a it's a
device that then it has a phone number
associated with it and when you dial the
phone number then it like makes this
noise and then you can enter in other
numbers with your phone and then those
numbers that you enter in will show up
on the beeper when it beeps and
typically you would just put your phone
number in the beeper and so then when
you sent it
I would like my my beeper would beep and
I would look at it and it would have a
phone number on it and that's the number
that I would then call once I got to a
phone right but the person calling
didn't have to do anything except call
to call the beeper they had to put in
their message because sometimes you were
put in you put in a phone number and
then you put 911 there was an emergency
it would just mean call me back as soon
as possible this is urgent or didn't
people call them buzzers as well I know
don't call them buzzers never not in
major pager Skype a Skype Asian right
sleeper and you would if you put like
buzzers just go on four three one four
three just met I love you
so other engineers would would say they
loved me occasionally I guess yeah
that's that's a sweet and you it made
you feel important when you're like in
the middle of a conversation or you're
walking around a facility and all of a
sudden you're beeping you're like up and
you I would just got poached you I would
have to just got Bose I remember I had
this cool technique of like I would pull
it off of my belt and look at it because
sure it was very cool the numbers were
so small you had to like really hold it
up to your eye and that was a way to
tell everybody around you I have been
issued a beeper I can see you don't have
a functioning beeper my I have a
functioning beeper so then I would just
run I'd have to fight then you run into
the nearest phone to answer a 9-1-1
doctor's dot you know speaking of 911
doctors yeah all had them right they
still do actually beepers are still in
effect to use somebody's terminology
because they operate on they don't
operate it on cell
service they operate on a much more
reliable service really yes and that's
why what are they hiding on firemen
doctors what are the medical person now
different frequencies yeah it's it's a
different it's a different beeper
frequency I think it's like a radio wave
I think well I think they're already
away yeah some some degree just
different frequencies I don't know maybe
so I never had one but now you make me
feel like I should get one of those too
I should get one of those in beat myself
in a payphone well I mean and and it's
you're the most reliably reachable but
you're not and then you could have a
two-way pager when you you could page
something you could page a number back I
did not have one of those I was not I
was not a second-level manager at IBM as
they call it I was just a first level
peon yeah okay so you never even
experienced that you never had a beeper
no I never had a I never had a beeper
never never had a reason to have a
beeper ah nobody wanted to know wonder
why I wanted to beat me what I what a
loser
I mean what is just an unimportant
person you must have been yeah I was I
was siloed I was very important
I had to be reached do you remember for
nothing
dialing for one one for information now
for one one people use it as slang all I
did at least in like you know the 90s I
think they still do what's the for one
one on that you know give me the
download give me the info and of course
this is based on the fact that you could
dial for one one and you still can dial
for one one but this was a reliable
service before the Internet yes well to
get a small number usually just to get a
phone number of a place yeah so then you
could call them and give them more
whatever you talk to him you should talk
you could also get an address of a place
oh really
yeah you could get information I think I
never used it literally never used it I
don't know I don't like I don't know why
because it's a real person it's not a
machine
it's a real person it still exists it
still exists
and we're going to call it ha okay all
right so so are you gonna ask for a
number well let's find out bro city and
state please
what Des Moines Iowa say the name of the
business you want or say resident
risible what are you doing that's County
of Polk right no say the name of the
business you want or say resident I
would like to speak to a human he wants
me to a human one moment for an operator
yet just real quick I'm actually I don't
need a listing in Des Moines but I just
wanted if you have a quick second to
just talk about for one one as a service
supervisor I'm sorry yeah I I said Des
Moines Iowa but really what I meant was
I am I'm currently talking to a friend
about for one one service and the fact
that it still exists we wanted to call
and just like how popular is this
service still oh wow so what kind of
information so how long how long have
you been how long have you been doing it
20 years so like how how much smaller is
the department than it was 20 years ago
Wow okay and okay and we were just
talking we used to call to get phone
numbers but you can get phone numbers
addresses like what what what all can
you still get I mean yeah pretty much
phone numbers and addresses if it's
published there's not really much
like Yelp reviews no you can't get Yelp
reviews so you know for a while we did
like movie times but it just wasn't
worth it we stopped so it's really just
phone numbers and addresses what movies
have you seen lately we don't do that I
do have to go though I can't we don't
just chat either all we do is look up
numbers here okay well how about Bob
Jenkins in Des Moines Iowa Bob Jenkins
if you were on site ride Bob Jenkins
just call back so basically you can't
conduct a relationship with 401 won they
they you know they just can't check you
screwed that up for me man I was having
that's why I was telling you to be quiet
I was having a great conversation with
that woman she's completely open up she
was like a bit doing it for 20 years
there's a lot smaller like what movies
have you seen lately and then she got
pissed man and she wanted to go like he
said you couldn't chat I could have she
could have chatted with me that woman
would have talked to me for 17 to 20
minutes and it would have been amazing
we didn't even get her name twenty years
of just giving people exactly what they
need that that's probably satisfying and
draining she sounds satisfied so I never
called it did you call it I don't recall
ever calling for one one but I'm sure
like I mean my mom wanted to like see if
the Golden Corral was open early or
something you know I just used the phone
book that's so much work you gotta like
think about where things fall in the
alphabet phonebook that's another thing
we don't use anymore I mean they still
don't still stack up a phone book in
front of my house and I'll put it
directly in the recycle bin it's just I
feel guilty about it yeah what that was
stealing I wrote down you never I don't
know what thrilling oh I didn't know
what you said
what about dialing star-69 oh now I've
done that star-69
now if you beep star-69
that means something else dirty but if
you dial star-69 it would give you the
last number that called you yeah it was
the pretty was the it was what killed
prank calling yes but if you were prank
calling you could dial what could you
dial to make your number unlisted before
you dial it star what star 68 or
something there was like star 96 you
could block your your call before you
dialed you could do that in order to
block people's ability to see I don't
know one caller ID but you could dial
something but we did it all the time it
was the counter to star 69 star 69 was
it was like if the phone was ringing and
you couldn't get to it yeah and you you
were kind of expect well yes you want to
know who called you and you didn't have
an answering machine or they didn't
leave an answer it was just you I guess
it would just drive people nuts so they
would pay extra who is that that called
who was that to called what star 67 was
how you block turn beam star 69 and I'm
pretty I would assume that this still
all works on landlines like I said I've
got one I'm gonna test it
I don't remember using that one that
much I don't you know if somebody if I
didn't answer the phone again you just
like we weren't was that I don't know
they'll call back later we also weren't
adults right when this was the way
things were I think I did I probably did
it a couple of times thinking that maybe
I'd gotten a phone call from a girl or
something yeah you know I remember uh
another thing on my list that I that I
did do was I would all the phones in
your house were connected so ho it
wasn't like every person had their own
phone line I mean party line man or at
least within the house
yeah within the house and so if my my
stepsister at the time was like talking
to her boyfriend I could like pick up my
Garfield phone gingerly his eyes would
open and then I would I was just like Oh
cover up the honey Hawk hole you evaced
eavesdrop see what I could learn what
did you learn I know nothing I don't
know I know a lot now so I probably some
of it came from then he
I think you were that little brother
that little that little half step
brother not even half brother yeah I
didn't that little wasn't it stick
brother I didn't do it constantly but I
would do it so violating our privacy I
mean I never listened to my brother's
phone calls so free to do that but the
parents could listen in to could just
get a little I mean but you would hear
that breathing like get out the phone
link well I would get that I'm saying
she would hear my breathing you got to
be blood you got to be better than to
let the breath be heard well he got a a
man got a breathe breathe you pull away
from them microphone to breathe
did you so Ori or you would just be on
and my mom still has a landline and like
I'll call and like Lewis I'll answer I'm
talking to him and then he'll talk to me
for a while and then all of a sudden
he'll disability so and then mom will
get on the phone in the bedroom then
they're both on the phone well that
that's very that's so easy that's two
people at a speakerphone yes that's
something that is lost that was nice
cannot be replicated yeah it's without
the land people I don't have a land on a
closed microphone speaking into your ear
it's like a conference call yeah it's
like you'd have conference calls with
like family members all the time you
know mm-hmm mom and Luis in different
rooms just talking away hmm well I would
talk to my mom for a long time and then
I realize Luis would all of a sudden
after like talking it for like 20
minutes all of a sudden
well I'm i'ma go i'ma let y'all talk oh
I kind of forgot he was still all here
take 20 minutes of it I still do have a
landline we got it
well when you get like game eight they
try to make it your service and stuff
you can get it and my wife was like yeah
let's get it because you know we've got
kids and you know they need to get in
touch with us because at the time when
we when we when we bought the current
neither the kids had a cellphone right
but if they're there and Waterford
doesn't have a cellphone and sometimes
for short stints he's on his own like
when we go out on the Prairie you know
to bring back a deer okay he you know he
he'll spend a few a few a few
fortnight's alone no but a few minutes
alone sometimes and it's like Shepherd
if anything happens and so I remember I
was like I had to show them how to use
the phone and apparently it's not as
simple as I remember at least they did
not understand like no you figured up
he's making a noise that's called a dial
tone yeah then you have to press the
buttons and but you like just effect
they're pressing buttons that are not on
a touchscreen and like they couldn't we
asked them all the way in to know that
they had like registered the number and
it was just like all these little things
really no you actually you didn't you
know know that you didn't hit that you
didn't hit it you didn't hit it you know
how you didn't hit it because you didn't
hear it yeah when you hit the number
you'll hear to fake the associated tone
with that particular number dial yeah
eventually they got it you're right
though dial tones don't exist give me
another one off your list
remembering phone numbers right yeah
there was a time in our lives when there
was like drawers in my brain they were
dedicated to people's phone numbers I
thought we could have a fun little
exercise now obviously Kiko we're going
to have to edit these but I want to
throw out someone's phone number from
the past now let's start with well I
think it's let's start with I'm gonna
start with your phone number when you
lived on in that part before you move to
Gregory circle yeah my first house yeah
that's it
that's crazy hold on cuz what how old
were you when you mean first of all how
old were you when you moved to Gregory
Circle
what great I think I was
twelve right so we're talking about I
just recalled your phone number from
first second third fourth fifth grade 20
the first five years of our friendship
yeah and then I moved and do you
remember my phone number once I moved
this is more recent this should be a
little easier that's it I mean you were
in one house that's crazy
so I know yours is easy yes so that's
easy but do you remember our phone
number in college maybe it was our dorm
room number not a clue
not a clue like that is it was the NC
State numbers were mm-hmm
you remember the next part no oh okay
that it okay interestingly I had him I
think I've actually used that for things
Oh like your password no like your bank
pin no like when you're like trying to
find like we're trying to like I don't
have anything that has that now but
looking like a Google number I mean I
don't know your phone number now like I
knew I knew you're North Carolina phone
number I don't know but when you got a
new phone number I don't I don't know it
well look that's gone right so I know my
wife's number I know my number but I
mean we've had him a long time I don't
know I don't know my kids phone numbers
that's kind of that's actually a bit
scary so I did that so I want to talk
about that specifically related to this
so obviously there were very good
reasons to know these these phone
numbers but and I still know your phone
number because it's the phone number
that you got the same year that I got my
original phone number anything with
Ghana phone number I've you know I've
changed my phone number but you should
know your family members now your
immediate family and then you should
also know emergency contact
like next of kin yeah you should have
the kind of a wake-up call or we should
just we should use for one one like some
like my kids need to get in touch with
me for one one it
yeah but you might not be in for one one
in fact I should not be if we've done
this right if we've done things the
right way you're not in for one one yes
sure so what tests that but okay because
I had this fear you know going back to
speaking of pay phones it's like okay
run out of gas with a dead phone like
that's a bit of a running out of gas
with a phone that's not currently
working vultures circling and I'm
talking about I'm not talking about
being out in the wilderness sometime I'm
just like being in like Anaheim you hear
I'm saying like at that point you're
like okay now I'm gonna be the guy that
goes up to people and says can I use
your phone
and now I'm not a gracious person when
strangers come up to me in need I always
just assume that they're scammers and it
kind of feels like can I use your
toothbrush ready intimate cuz what you
know cuz you've got those people who
come up to you at the gas like I use
this thing on the crapper man you got
those people that come up to you at the
gas station and they've got a story and
then they do it they go up to every
person you know that this is a scam like
99% of the time you hand them your phone
they're just gonna run no they're not
asking for the phone they're asking for
like a couple of bucks now and just as a
policy I'd not I don't do I give to a
lot of things but I don't give to those
people because I think that I can't
verify this is just seem shady right
yeah but I don't want to be that guy
that has to go and ask a stranger for
the phone now I guess I did do you
wouldn't know what number to call right
well that's a yeah so double whammy you
get in that situation and you don't know
the number so I guess you could we do
now know that for when one is still
available but I don't think that a lot
of people that we would want to call are
on for one one so I know my wife's phone
number got that memorized it's the same
one that she had when I got her her
first cell phone when she was 20 years
old so I think I'm okay but I don't know
I don't know my parents my kids know my
number they know mine no I think my kids
know my new number they don't know
Jessie's number but how would you know
if they knew it cuz you don't know it
you'd have to pull it up on your phone
again but but beyond those numbers that
you need for emergency situations it
does not other than just for your own
personal memory exercise and trying to
like stave off degenerative disease or
something like that there's really no
reason to keep your numbers in your head
because you can easily just offload it
to your phone and if you if you are
seriously one of those people that you
do not have I guess there are still
people out there who have a smartphone
but do not have their contacts backed up
in a cloud situation and some service
like you need to do that like there's no
reason that your phone should be the
only place that you have these phone
numbers that just you know make an
adjustment all right I got I got another
thank me later on my list of speaking of
dialing things for information we would
dial a number and it was the local bank
first federal bank to get the exact time
and temperature
hold on I'm assuming that you wrote this
phone number down so we can call it
I wrote down well I don't I looked it up
and it doesn't exist so I have another
number that yes I called the first
federal number literally and I think I
can remember this number for we would
call them because here's what I happened
like what was the number do you remember
that Lightning would strike a Lightning
would strike just one lightning power
would go out and then you're like I got
to reset my phone's but how do you do
that will you call the bank first
federal time 758 right first federal
temperature 49 degrees yeah yeah so
you've called it for time when you need
to reset the time you caught it for
temperature when you wanted you want to
know what the temperature wasn't you
didn't want to sit around wait for Greg
vishal to come on and tell you you know
what the temperature was yeah and I
called it all the time when I was
getting ready to go to school and I was
like how cold is it outside I would call
first federal so I could get the freakin
temperature to know if I needed to put a
jacket on
I watched the weather for that but watch
the weather win everything the morning
you watch the weather in the morning oh
yeah
I loved the weatherman literally I loved
the weatherman I thought so we don't
know yet professor you're telling me
that you can't call that number because
I swear within the last five years I've
called that number when I was at home
well there's lots of places where you
could call popcorn seven six seven 2676
and get a pre-recorded voice telling you
the time that does not work anymore but
you can dial 202 76240 no.1 which i
think is the Naval Observatory and it'll
give you the exact Eastern Standard Time
so let's call that one let's forget what
time it is and this will be Eastern
Standard Time there's a Mountain
Standard time number US Naval
Observatory master clock at the tone
eastern standard time 21 hours 10
minutes 15 seconds 2 hours 10 minutes 20
seconds US Naval Observatory master
clock at the tone eastern standard time
21 hours 10 minutes 30 seconds people
hours 10 minutes 35 seconds he's
repeating himself now I like that guy's
voice yeah I want that guy to be my Siri
is that possible no it's not so yeah I
mean that's we used to dial a number to
figure out what time it was now I
probably should have talked about this
with remembering phone numbers but
rolodex role a day the rolodex you're
talking about an address book that is on
a swivel you didn't have one of these in
your house no we I never had a rolodex
that's like something that like and like
a add an adman and like Mad Men had on
their desk you had a rolodex wait we had
a version of a rolodex that my my I need
in know like what is my cousin's number
something that my mom would go in the
little all the cards were organized and
she would flip through him he was a
rolodex it was a roller I may not have
been the brand name rolodex which I'm
going to tell you
about because it's absolutely
fascinating tell me about it okay so the
rolodex which just to explain it was
basically like this ringed collection of
cards that you could write numbers and
names on and organize them by
alphabetical order and put anything in
any information you want this thing was
invented by roll edex Arnold Neustadter
he was a 20th century inventor from
Brooklyn now he also invented before
this the swivel decks which was a device
that kept ink bottles from spilling I
don't know for what purpose
well you because you don't want to spill
your ink man he also invented the clip
Oh Dex Oh sensing a theme here Arnold
what is that for peg it was a device
that attached to the knees of
stenographers to keep their pads for
moving not you know their pads the ones
that ruined their knees and he also made
little he changed things up the punched
the punched punched which was a hole
puncher made holes in papers now then he
came along prolific and winner with the
rolodex now the funny thing is is like
there was an article in Gizmodo by Anna
Jane Grossman who wrote that book
obsolete which I did not read but saw
the cover of and thought I would like to
read which is like 98% of books went
with me and she talked about how the
daughter talked about how the dad was
really anal and he try to remember
everything and whenever someone she took
a message from someone he would be like
I want you to get their name their
callback number their address the reason
for calling Lee he he had this like list
that you had to do and in the household
if you took a message so this was right
down his alley was to organize
information in this way by the way that
is a flashback for me is being taught
how to take messages for people in the
house like for my mom and dad name
number and reason for yeah for call me
what you and you'd write it down uni and
so as a kid I remember that system did
you have to say the residents or did you
say hello I don't have to do offline
rows I would say hello but like I think
the jubie's did
maybe residence QB residence anybody
with class did did residents who didn't
have class yeah so he invented this in
the 50s then by the 80s the rolodex had
become such an icon that lawsuits were
filed by companies who accused former
employees of taking them with them when
they left just like he's taken his
rolodex with him yeah he's a euphemism
but it's based in a literal truth in
that depending on what the business you
were in like a ad man like you were
talking about yeah your rolodex your
physical rolodex all those readily value
the context the contacts that you may
you're talking about backing up your
contacts to the cloud yes yeah that
thing became extremely valued did you
have for business a fact they didn't
have backup rolodexes I don't think
because okay so models were selling for
$200 at the time even though people
often value valued them at prices far
higher than that once they got filled up
listen to this sure in fact an entire
episode of moonlighting remember
moonlighting with Bruce Willis sitcom
simple Shepherd was devoted to one
stolen rolodex being held ransom for
$50,000 an entire episode is a fictional
world I was fictional but a big rolodex
it stands up to $50,000 in a fictional
world you know it would be cool to like
I bet you you can buy rolodexes now off
of ebay that are like fully populated
and that would be fascinating well yeah
what but you can also buy brand-new ones
because I'm not in the band the
interview that this woman this author
conducted with the daughter of Arnold
mm-hmm she said you know I'm talking
about this from my book obsolete and she
and the girl got a little upset and was
like if they're not obsolete people
still buy them as toys and they're still
sold she probably says that because she
gets a little bit of that my name even
to this day my Nana and Papa they didn't
have a Rolodex they would get the phone
was beside the calendar and then the top
of the calendar had an area where you
would write down numbers so every year
they would kind of have to start over
like transfer over the most important
numbers and then she you'd like scribble
all over the top of the calendar with
like it hadn't by the end of the year
would have numbers all over it and then
she would repeat them
she wanted to hold on to I think so she
must have I mean it's an interesting
system doesn't seem very efficient but
at the same time you know cuz you they
are completely evaluate every single
year you're on the phone and you're just
up you know write down your number or
write down the number I need to call and
then you call it you know that's where
you need it anyway what if Bob Jenkins
in Des Moines Iowa was listening he is
yes he's freaking out remember just
answering machines yes I remember I mean
I don't even use voicemail you know if
if it's just a black hole for me man my
mom called me this morning she was like
I was calling you and I was I was trying
to leave a voicemail and you called me
back and I'm like I almost don't leave
voicemails just you know text me yeah
that's how voicemails most mailboxes are
obsolete but I remember whenever we
would come home from anything I would
run as a kid I would run into the living
room and I would press play on our
cassette tape run yeah answering machine
and you'd hear the beep and then you'd
hear the the recording the analog
recording that somebody left and then it
would be pagainst out of time and
sometimes they'd have to call back leave
a second voicemail to continue their
thought right and then I don't know it's
just it was an exciting moment because
every second in your that you're out in
the world you're not receiving calls you
know it's this sensation of like a build
up of of expectation it's like well I
there was always something to look
forward to I would like I said I would
bust in the door and I can't wait to
hear who had left a message on your
mom's answering machine yeah it was just
exciting to me I bet I don't remember
something happened while we were gone
when he called I well first of all I
definitely did not have an answering
machine when I was living at home with
my parents they did not have they didn't
yeah your family didn't own an answering
machine
not for the longest time I remember I
remember week when we may be at the very
tail end of high school I was very
fascinated don't think we had one and I
think
that's weird
well I don't think it's that weird I
don't think I think there was a lot of
families that didn't have an answering
machine it's one of those things that
once you had it maybe I'm blocking it
out but I'm pretty sure that we did not
have felt like we could live without
Jordy of the time that I lived there and
then did we have an answering machine in
the college dorm room because I know I
had one when I first got our college
dorm room phone number had had voice
mail boxes and like he would pick up the
phone and it would the dial tone would
be different different and then it was
beeping if it was if it was a it was a
broken dial tone and I mean you got a
message and then you would put in your
code and it would lead to either my
voice box well voice mail
I'd lead to my voice box I would be
speaking yeah my code 1958 but do you
remember the commercial where they would
sell greetings
it was called crazy calls crazy calls a
tape of different songs and funny
recordings for answering machines no
nobody's home nobody's home nobody's
home nobody's home nobody's home and
then there were did you didn't use this
service I just remember I wanted it so
how would you get the how would you get
it onto your answer machine it was seven
songs I looked this up it was it was
called crazy calls and it was seven
different tracks on a cassette tape that
would fit in in your in your answering
machine and your answering machine would
know how to it would queue up the tape
and then play it and then it would
record but sometimes it would have to
fast for it one tape one tape has the
greeting and the message now I know it's
a separate tape so there was a greeting
tape and then a recording tape that's
how it worked and I remember there was a
wrap on that it was like leave your
message we're not home believe your
message at the tone and then it was good
one it was what it's like wait for the
beep wait for the beep he kept saying
that it was like a
and there's also the classic hello that
wasn't one of these seven gotcha I'm not
how do annoying whoever did that should
be ashamed of yourself I wanted those
tapes so bad but you're right yeah that
was the peak of technology for me was
like little tapes oh when the oh we got
that one too first it was the bigger
tapes and then you would get an
associate it would have those little
tapes that like you put like the hand
recorder was like note to self but then
it went to with the one I we had the one
we had when we first got married was no
tape yeah kind of digital it was it was
being recorded locally and in there
somehow and we had that for we had a
regular phone with an answering machine
up until they started putting voice mail
built into your phone service which
happened was widespread some had some
time like the early 2000s that's when
you just started doing it that way did
you have anything else on your list I
did phones with cables the tether yeah
the the the spiral cordage the phone I
have at home has a cable on it it's not
cordless cuz I remember really when my
mom got a cordless phone and we were
like what she can walk from room to room
while on the phone and it was just like
we are rich yeah I remember first time
we got one of those I called you I bet I
remember walking out on the front lawn
I was like I'm alone I'm outside talking
on the phone so rich uncle blowing my
own mind my neighbors can see me yeah
because before that I'm talking on the
phone outdoors well and you had to think
about where where the phones were I mean
everybody had most people had a phone in
every room like like you had a phone in
each bedroom so you can have those
the conversations with your lady friends
that you didn't want your parents to
hear but even then like you had the
phone and then you had to like you
stretched the cord like if you wanted to
like you know sit in your chair lay down
on your bed and you got like there's you
know the court is its tether yeah yeah
maybe you could get the whole phone like
you could take all of Garfield and bring
him into bed with you but you got to
make sure that the cord from Garfield to
the wall is long enough for that right
and I were I do remember back to like
the in the house party line thing what
would actually happen the most not me
eavesdropping on my stepsister would be
I would be on the phone with like my
girlfriend or something and then my mom
on the other side of the house would
need to make a phone call and she would
just pick up the phone and I'll be up
mom I'm on the phone it was like and
then she would oh I'm sorry
well she'd be like well I need to use
the phone so in cordless you need to get
off and cordless you know back on after
I call were much easier to tell time and
date when somebody had interrupted so if
you had the classic phone either a
rotary phone phone or just a non corded
phone a non cordless phone you get your
finger and you'd stick it up under the
receiver and hold down those two clear
pegs that would come out that would
indicate that this phone is open the
phone lines open and you'd hold it down
and then you to open it up you get the
phone in position and then you turn it
like this so you wouldn't breathe into
the phone and then you very very very
quietly so you did eavesdrop on your
brother no I just know how to do it I
just know the tech you had the power but
she didn't wield it but with a cordless
phone it was very obvious like you could
like hear somebody just came into the
conversation yeah
my mom on the phone and then every once
in a while you can replicate this
situation when you're charging your
phone and you get a phone call and you
don't want to stop charging it and
you're like down there next to your
bedside table yeah yeah you can feel I'm
doing it the old-fashioned way
you can feel what it was like to tell
this do you have anything else mm-hmm
but you do I think as we as our custom
now
have a recommendation oh yeah do your
biscuit ears so thanks for taking a trip
down memory lane let us know hashtag ear
biscuits
what phone related nostalgia was brought
to your mind something you remember
about the way phones used to be hashtag
ear biscuits and now it's time to get
some Rex in effect I'm gonna work on
that I'm gonna I'm gonna check baby
check baby well you know it's a rump
shaker it's a song yeah right
speaking of so that's my recommendation
this week is a song I love it when I
find a song it's like whoa I'm something
about this song is special I never even
knew it existed hmm I played this for
Rhett earlier today yeah and would you
agree that this is a this isn't this is
a song not to be missed
it's very notable it's it's weird I
think it has special it I knew when you
are playing it exactly why you were
playing it for me
I don't necessarily know that that would
translate to yeah everyone right but you
were playing it for me because you were
like the person who sang this song at
the time that they sang it and then the
way that it sounds
all of those things are going to be a
little bit difficult for you to
reconcile and it's gonna be a little bit
of a trip and you were right my friend
yeah and so you know I don't know where
it's gonna strike you and I will say
that I'm not given an endorsement of
anybody's of this artists personal
beliefs of what they may put on Twitter
now no telling does he have a Twitter
account yeah so don't go there just
enjoy the song for what it is but this
song is called behind your eyes by the
Charlie Daniels thing
you may know the Charlie Daniels Band
from the Devil Went Down to Georgia he
was looking for a soul to steal he was
in abide and he was way behind and he
was willing to make a deal
mm-hmm good little song that's what he's
known for most um even when we went to
New Orleans and we went to that like
dueling piano bar
started playing that song and got two
and it's a good song yeah but this song
behind your eyes is the song before that
song on the album and it is like night
and day different in terms of like the
genre it's not this like you know you
may consider Devil Went Down to Georgia
like a redneck fiddle song mm-hmm I
think that's the official genre um on on
iTunes
redneck fiddle the sound is the sound in
well production of that song very
unexpectedly noseband
late 70s rock kind of thing and then
these which is one of my favorite things
is harmonic harmonizing lead guitars
like to Telecasters playing which is a
supplementary it's a that's solos it's
not limited to but it is a big southern
rock thing when he was in that I think
this is 1979 it's a good year uh so yeah
just think of think of that think of me
when you listen to that song and uh it
may it may surprise you here's the being
surprised it's my recommendation you
know what you got to keep surprising
yourself don't ever stop surprising
yourself go outside on your phone talk
in the yard untethered if you don't know
your own phone number memorize that
starting with you Rhett yeah I'm gonna
do that all right
well speak at you next week thanks for
hanging out with us to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]